- Well, speaking of
your son and basketball,
it looks like he's got
you coaching him now.
So let's see how this looks.
- [Idina] Oh Okay.
(ball bouncing)
Yes!
[ Idina] Did you see my alley-hoop?
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] Look at that
assist that was amazing.
(audience cheering)
(Idina clapping)
- Did you hear though?
Did you hear I placed that, Kelly?
- The note.
- you know,
'cause you're a singer.
So it was like yes!
(Kelly laughs)
That's really good, she knows.
So I'm not hurting my voice.
- Yeah.
- I like, I can do my, my very, my joy is
is like up there in the range.
- See and people don't realize
- Supported.
- that like, that's,
I can't actually listen to my voice,
my speaking voice like anything
'cause I sound nasally to me
because-
- You do? You don't sound nasally.
- Well, it's easier on my vocal chords.
And we sing so often.
We work so much.
It's easier when you're coming up
and it's a little nasally,
- [Idina] Yeah.
- it's a little higher.
- So it's probably annoying to y'all,
but we don't care. (laughs)
(audience laughs)
- But also if I'm ever in the car
and there's like somebody stops short
and I'm worried or something,
I'll be like, watch out!
You know?
(Kelly laughs)
Or if I'm on a rollercoaster.
- Oh my God.
- On a rollercoaster,
I go like, lay hands off.
- This is so scary.
- I even did it,
you're gonna think I'm weird.
But when I was in labor, I
was like, the babies coming.
(both laughing)
'Cause God knows if I
had a concert to go to,
I didn't wanna hurt my
vocal chords, you know.
- Oh my God, if you
would've just screamed out
slash sang "Let It Go" in that moment,
you would've made a lot of people's lives.
♪ Let it go ♪
(Idina laughs)
(audience clapping)
- That would've been,
that would have made a lot
of people's moments in life.
All right (laughs) that's
how I'm going to use that.
- [Idina] You get it right?
- I do,
but now I want to ride
rollercoasters with you. (laughs)
(audience laughing)
'Cause I just, my,
♪ Hands up ♪
- It's just like
(Kelly laughs)
♪ Into the unknown ♪
- (laughs) While they're going,
I can't stop picturing it.
♪ I'm crowning ♪
- Oh my God, I love you so much.